nimm doch gleich zwei eine Süßigkeit die
den Tagesbedarf an Vitaminen abdeckt
cleveres Marketing oder ein wahr
gewordener Traum Sebastian baut sie nach
mein Gott beim reinkippen werde ich
schon ganz vitalisiert hier und zeigt
warum man vielleicht doch nur ein Bonbon
nehmen sollte
[Musik]
ich bin in Aachen in einem
süßwarentechnologie-center die haben die
richtige Maschine um so viele Säfte und
Vitamine in so einem kleinen Format zu
verstecken dazu ist Sebastian lege mit
Lebensmittel Ingenieur Erato
verabredet hallo hallo
ja ein bisschen was mitgebracht
verschiedene
Fruchtsaftkonzentrate und viele Vitamine
alles Zutaten für einen nimm zwei Bonbon
das liest sich auf der Zutatenliste
natürlich super wow denk Mann für den
Bonbon Nachbau verwenden Sebastian und
horche Glukose Sirup jede Menge Zucker
und Wasser im Kocher muss die
Zuckermasse eine Temperatur von 138 Grad
erreichen
[Musik]
ungefähr 30 Minuten in der Zeit mischt
das Team die cremige Füllung an die
besteht aus Glucose und fructose-sirup
also Zucker Milch sorgt für Textur sechs
Fruchtsaftkonzentrate färben die Masse
eine kleine Menge reicht aus das ist ja
gar nichts
für die richtige Konsistenz muss die
Füllmasse aufkochen bis 100 12 Grad dann
wird die Masse ein bisschen
okay das ist ganz ganz wichtig bei
solchen Produkten die Temperatur geführt
werden da kommt es auf einen Grad drauf
an dass sie perfekt werden sehr wichtig
sobald die Masse etwas abgekühlt ist
Reichert Sebastian sie künstlich an mit
Aroma und 9 Vitaminen wie beim Original
machen wir Vitamin B12
wir ziehen
Vitamin C
[Musik]
Vitamin B1 mein Gott beim reinkippen
werde ich schon ganz vitalisiert hier
Vitamin E
Vitamin B2 hier ist die Folsäure eine
Füllung aus Zucker und zugesetzten
Vitamine extra rot durch konzentrierten
Fruchtsaft so leuchtet sie später im
Bonbon besser
in der Zwischenzeit ist die Bonbonmasse
fertig
[Musik]
und sehr gefährlich
sieht aus wie Honig jetzt erst nach dem
Kochen kommen die restlichen Zutaten
dazu ein klein wenig Saftkonzentrat für
die Farbe
dazu Aroma für den Zitrusgeschmack
[Musik]
jetzt ein bisschen Zitronensäure alles
alles ja ein bisschen
Geschmack die Masse wird auf einem Tisch
ausgebreitet damit die Temperatur sinkt
[Musik]
sind das sieht aus wie Lava die
über den Tisch
Sebastian und horche kneten die
Zuckermasse ständig so kühlt sie
gleichmäßig ab was meinst du ist okay
perfekt ja
70 Grad das heißt sie steif genug aber
immer noch elastisch dass wir gleich die
Füllung da reinbekommen der Behälter mit
der Füllung ist an eine Maschine für
hardcaramelle angeschlossen sie pumpt
die Flüssigkeit zwischen vier
kegelrollen
liegt die warme Masse in die Maschine
die kegelrollen sorgen dafür dass Sie
das füllungsrohr umschließt
die Rollen drücken die Masse zusammen
und schieben sie Stück für Stück nach
vorne
die Rollen sind hier temperiert damit
die Masse immer Temperatur geführt
perfekt geformt werden kann
die Füllung aus dem Ohr an dieser Stelle
wird die Masse immer schmaler
die Maschine formt sieht zu einem dünnen
Strang in die Mitte gepumpt die rote
Füllung der Strang läuft in die
prägeanlage der Einsatz presst die Masse
von beiden Seiten zu kleinen Bonbons
dann kommen sie aufs kühlwand
jetzt sind sie außen fest und innen
flüssig
da sind sie unsere kleinen Vitamin
Bomben sieht aber schon witzig aus oder
[Musik]
Zuckerbonbons für das gute Gewissen mit
vielen zugesetzten Vitaminen und 1,3%
Fruchtsaftkonzentrat wird naschen so
einfach gesund
ein kleiner Zusatz von
Fruchtsaftkonzentrat ist letztlich eine
Lösung Frucht und pflanzenkonzentrate
sind ganz intensive Verarbeitung von
ganz ursprünglichen Lebensmitteln was im
Wesentlichen noch enthalten ist sind die
Farbstoffe aber ein Urteil der Vitamine
die oftmals hitzeempfindlich sind gehen
wir diesen Verarbeitungsprozessen
verloren das ungesunde Lebensmittel wird
dadurch nicht gesund der vitaminzusatz
ist günstig pro 240 Gramm Packung
verarbeitet der Hersteller knapp ein
Gramm Vitamine rund 60 Prozent davon
sind Vitamin C das kostet weniger als
einen halben Cent
Vitaminpulver wird in der Regel
synthetisch hergestellt zum Beispiel auf
Basis von Robben ziehen oder durch den
Einsatz von gentechnisch veränderten
Bakterien die chemische Herstellung
steht in der Kritik giftige Abwässer und
Abgase sollen zu enormen Umweltschäden
führen die meisten synthetischen
Vitamine kommen aus China
[Musik]
die Lebensmittelindustrie nutzt sie als
Verkaufsstrategie besonders für
hochverarbeitete Produkte mit viel Fett
oder Zucker aus Sicht des
Verbraucherschutzes ist das riskant
Produkte wie nimmt zwei sind leider sehr
kritisch denn hier so riert man ja dem
Verbraucher das ist eine gesunde
Süßigkeit und das kann dann am Ende dazu
führen der Name sagt es ja auch schon
nimm zwei davon darf man ruhig mal ein
bisschen mehr essen nimm zwei verspricht
bereits mit wenigen Bonbons können
Kinder und Erwachsene ihren Tagesbedarf
an neuen verschiedenen Vitaminen Decken
klingt gut und praktisch aus
medizinischer Sicht gibt es Bedenken
das Problem bei künstlichen Vitaminen
ist dass diese Zusätze eben tatsächlich
nur das Vitamin an sich ersetzen ein
ursprüngliches Lebensmittel enthält aber
nicht nur Vitamine sondern auch viele
Begleitstoffe sekundäre Pflanzenstoffe
Ballaststoffe Mineralien und auch die
tragen zu unserer Gesundheit bei
Bonbons sind und bleiben Süßigkeiten für
den Tagesbedarf an Vitamin C reichen
bereits zwei Orangen die sind dann auch
wirklich gesund
[Musik]